hey what's going on everybody before we
get started I want to mention the
giveaway one last time before it ends
because there is only a few days left
for you to enter and have your chance to
win one of these prizes I will be given
away both of these items in the first
person that is randomly selected gets to
pick which prize they won and the second
person that is randomly selected will
get the other prize and I will draw both
names on the same day so go down into
the description and click on that link
which provides multiple ways for you to
enter so you can increase your chances
of winning and if you were one of the
people that won the Twitter contests I
held as soon as this giveaway ends I
will be mailing everything out on the
same day so I wanted to let you know it
didn't get lost in the shuffle
thank you for your patience and good
luck everyone now let's get started
together today I want to talk about a
potential marriage I've seen several
videos that I've been made about many
possible marriages that could be taking
place during season seven or season
eight but I have yet to see any of the
channels that I follow make a video
about Oriya and gender getting married
but this is a very popular discussion
amongst the community and I've been
asked about these two characters so many
times in the comments section that I
decided to make a video about this topic
so let's discuss this a little bit and
see if it's likely to happen we know
that Aria and Gendry have had a very
good relationship with each other
Aria made Gendry when she was still just
a child and even though Gendry was a
young man at the time they still became
friends and protected one another by
helping each other keep their identities
a secret even though it could have
gotten either one of them killed but
their relationship at the time didn't
come across these two people that were
physically attracted to each other it
was almost like a brother and sister
relationship and we also know from a
quote that Aria said herself she didn't
even want to settle down and have a
family of her own anyway you will marry
a high Lord and rule his castle and your
son's shall be nice
and princes and Lords no that's not me
it's easy to see that aria is very
independent and I could also very easily
see her living out the rest of her life
without ever settling down even though
she became very close with ginjury and
trusted him but that doesn't mean it
will play out that way let's be honest
there are a lot of kids who say they
will never have a boyfriend or
girlfriend when they are that young but
there always comes a time when they
start to look at the opposite sex a
little bit differently the thought of
them having cooties quickly slips away
and the same even goes for Aria back in
season two when Aria and Gendry were at
harrenhal together there was a scene
when Aria looked at Gendry with those
hungry eyes have a look for yourself
ladies you know exactly what was running
through her mind when she gave ginjury
that look she wanted to swing his hammer
and play with his sword but that doesn't
mean they want to get married does it
and besides
Gendry and Aria are no longer with each
other Gendry was even willingly ready to
go separate ways with Aria when he
decided he wanted to stay with the
Brotherhood without banners which was
absolutely devastating to Aria not only
because of how dangerous it would have
been for ginjury but Aria did not like
the fact of leaving without Gendry by
her side so much so that she even told
him how strongly she felt about the
relationship that they had formed
unfortunately for Gendry at the time we
know what ended up happening instead the
Brotherhood sold ginjury off to
Melisandre which was another devastating
blow to Aria but also another sign of
how strongly Aria felt about injury Aria
knew that Melisandre intended on hurting
injury and ever since that day Aria has
planned on killing Melisandre for taking
him away which we could end up seeing
her do in the episodes to come but
thankfully sir Davos came through in the
clutch and sent ginjury off on a small
boat giving him his freedom and life
back ever since then Aria and Gendry
have not seen each other nor do they
even know if either one is alive but
thanks to all the spoilers that have
came out we know that Gendry will make
his triumphant return to the show during
season 7 and not only is Gendry coming
back but it looks like jon is going to
be taking him under his wing which
increases the chances of Aria in Gendry
meeting again by a thousand percent in
my opinion Aria told Jack in Agoura she
was going home and after a quick layover
in the twins
Aria should be landing at Winterfell by
midseason 7 right around the same time
John and Gendry will set sail from
Dragonstone to head north so if you
thought this theory was dead you're
wrong this is the height that was
promised but and this is a big but just
because Aria and Gendry will meet again
doesn't mean they're going to get
married because no matter how much Aria
likes her love's ginjury we still know
she told her father she was not going to
live the life of a typical woman but
let's look at it like this though I
think it's safe to say that most of us
believe the stark children have a strong
connection to their direwolves
and their fate
also has a very strong connection to the
names of their direwolves so let's think
about Aria's dire wolf Nymeria and who
she was named after what does not ya
mean and does it represent what we could
see from aria in the future Nymeria was
known as a warrior queen which does
sound a bit like arias personality but
it also says although Nymeria is
remembered as a warrior queen this is
somewhat of a generalization Nymeria was
not herself a warrior who engaged in
personal combat but a skilled general
and commander similar to how Tywin
Lannister was no longer a warrior but
still one of the keenest military
strategists in Westeros now that's a
very interesting comparison considering
Tywin Lannister did kind of mentor Arya
even though this is different from the
books could this be a sneak peek into
arias future one other thing that should
be noted about Nymeria the warrior queen
she was not a single lady she was
married to a Marteau so if Arya does
follow the path of who she named her
direwolf after this could mean she may
end up getting married herself if you
have read George RR Martin's original
draft then you know that he did plan on
having arya fall in love with Jon but I
highly doubt he will still take her down
that same path since almost everything
in that original draft has now been
changed and since season seven and eight
are in the hands of Dan and Dave there's
no telling where they will take arias
character but it does feel like to me
that now that Gendry is back him and
Arya will reunite again and possibly be
some of the few remaining characters
left after the great war who will help
quote/unquote restore Westeros I do
think entry will be legitimized by John
or Daenerys I also think he will end up
with some of his own land but then again
I always go back to Ramsay's quote if
you think this has a happy ending then
you haven't been paying attention so
I'll leave you with one last quote from
Arya's first chapter in the Game of
Thrones novel Septim ordain says Arya
has the hands of a blacksmith hmm could
mean something it could mean nothing
comment below and give me your thoughts
on this topic though do you think Aria
and Gendry will end up together and do
you like the idea of them ending up
together personally I wouldn't be mad
either way I would be fine if they did
get married and I would also be fine if
Arya lived out the
for life by herself but give me your
thoughts about this there is the chance
that songs that may never get married
again
and if Daenerys does die then John
probably won't marry anyone either so
this could potentially be the only
marriage that matters in the very end
but give me your thoughts let me know
and I'll see you down on a comment
section bye
so you look you look stunning you lovely
okay so if you had to pick who would be
Westeros --is sexiest man alive gentry
Joe Dempsie that's really embarrassing
I've never said that and you may be
saying it I think that's a great pick
and you and Gendry have a special
relationship yeah